tras más de dos semanas de huelga y una
crisis en el suministro de combustibles
el gobierno decidió intervenir así lo
hizo saber durante una sesión de la
asamblea la primera ministra Elizabeth
born es un padre
las propuestas sobre la mesa por la
empresa exo móvil no son mínimas son
significativas por eso he pedido a los
perfectos como permite la ley que hagan
una requisición del personal necesario
para el funcionamiento de los depósitos
de la empresa un funcionario
con esta medida El Ejecutivo obliga a
los trabajadores de las refinerías de
eso Epson móvil y total energis a volver
a sus funciones y de esta forma mitigar
el impacto sobre el suministro de
combustibles en el país y es que en las
calles las filas para poder tanquear los
vehículos son interminables Pero los
sindicatos que exigen una mejora
salarial ante las ganancias
extraordinarias de las empresas
persisten en sus peticiones
compartimos por supuesto el sufrimiento
de todos los individuos y como todos
entendemos que uno necesita un vehículo
para ir al trabajo para el ocio o
incluso simplemente para las citas
médicas Pero entonces el personal que
hoy ejerce su derecho a la huelga no
está aquí para interrumpir solo está
aquí para mostrar su descontento para
defender la necesidad real de poder
vivir decentemente con sus trabajos
la huelga obligado a las empresas a
desconectar más del 60% de la capacidad
Nacional de refinado y a bloquear la
distribución de los depósitos de
combustible en un momento de escasez
mundial de derivados del petróleo